CBS News senior national security
analyst Fran Townsend worked with
Nielson in the George W Bush
administration Townsend was the
president's Homeland Security and
counterterrorism adviser Frank good
morning good morning John Fran here's
what I'm trying to figure out how much
of this was Nielsen's issue and how much
of it is the fact that the president is
in a system of separated powers where
Congress has to do the work that he
wants done well you make the point John
I think she was doing what she thought
was the limit of what she could do right
and she has repeatedly said and it's
true the you know Congress does need to
act if they don't like the policy of the
administration some of this can be be
wanted if they would simply update the
law allowing children to be returned to
their their country of origin just like
we do with Mexico and Canada for example
and sort of not have the the problem of
family separations well my friend let me
ask you I mean as John was saying the
president called Nielsen on Sunday
morning and said essentially shut down
the border shut it down to all migrants
shut it down to people seeking asylum
the secretary apparently has repeatedly
told the president sir some of that
stuff is illegal I just can't do that
what is going to change in terms of
immigration will anything change with
this firing well certainly certainly we
won't expect Mac alena nor any secretary
to be breaking the law and if the
president doesn't like the law the
administration is gonna have to work
with Congress to change some of it but
look there has been a surge I was down
at the border not ten days ago and and
the system is overwhelmed and so
something's got to give I think I you
know the president is understandably
frustrated with the increasing numbers
but firing Nielsen isn't going to change
that look they were prosecuting every
person who illegally crossed the border
and then the system got overwhelmed
which is why they pulled back from that
but that this is there's no solution to
this once they've pulled back from the
prosecution's the message to illegal
migrants is come on in because we're
you're now not gonna get prosecuted
until the law changes so any idea I know
you know her and you've worked with her
any idea how she's feeling she was there
with the President on Friday Sunday
she's out of a job do you think or does
she feel she got a fair shake here
look Gail I think she's she's done her
level best I think she's worked
tirelessly to to you know sort of
implement the President's agenda but
it's been a tough road she's had a
difficult 16 months she's defended
policies that she at times I think was
questioning and so look she served well
I think I think it's a relief for her to
be able to get out and move on just a
reminder - Thank You Fran that the
Secretary of Homeland Security deals
with just more than just the border they
deal with cyber threats so many other
things so those are gonna be important
and come up certainly at any
confirmation hearing Fran always good to
have you